this story is absolutely fascinating and
there's so much
that we can discuss but we should really
kind of start
with with a clip and uh one of the
really
kind of lightweight when it comes to you
know intellectually
one of the really lightweight republican
senators out there is a guy named
ron johnson he represents wisconsin
and he's gone completely off the deep
end in the past for example during a
recent congressional hearing
about the january sixth riots he
suggested that
the insurrectionists weren't really
trump supporters but it was some
combination
of provocateurs and fake trump
supporters and we're going to get to
that because it exposes his obvious lies
in a moment
but i want to start with a clip of ron
johnson recently going on the joe pags
radio show i don't know if this is an
online show or like a broadcast radio
but he went on this show and he said he
didn't feel threatened ron johnson
didn't feel threatened during the
january 6th riots now you might say well
why why didn't he feel threatened if
if they were you know provocateurs and
antifa or whoever
that should be threatening to him as a
republican right well no
he says he didn't feel threatened
because the rioters
were pro-trump people who loved the
country but
had they been black lives matter had
they been antifa
he might have been afraid take a look at
this clip does white supremacists
they don't really believe that but they
know there's a percentage of those that
they're telling that that will believe
it that's really the game right i mean
there's no way people you go to work
with every day really think
that you and i are white supremacists
because we believe in conservative
values right
no and let's face it i'm also criticized
because i've made the comment that
on january 6 i never felt threatened
because i
didn't and mainly because i knew that
even though
those thousands of people that were
marching to the capitol
were trying to pressure people like me
to vote the way they wanted me to vote
i knew those are people that love this
country that
truly respect law enforcement would
never do anything to break a law
and so i wasn't concerned now had the
tables been turned joe this got me in
trouble
had the tables been turned and president
trump won the election and those were
tens of thousands of black lives matter
and antifa
protesters i might have been a little
concerned wow
it's a big statement but you know it's a
true statement we see the the recent
history
well let's face it you know people
didn't board up their store fronts in in
metropolitan areas
in case joe biden won and now you take a
look at what's happening in minneapolis
the trial so there are just a ton of
things there to talk about now first of
all
it's hard to hear him say that and not
get the sense that he sort of means i
wasn't scared because the protesters
were white which of course they
were almost exclusively white if it had
been black people
under the banner of black lives matter
or antifa then i would have been scared
he does stop just short of saying that
so i'm sort of inferring i
admit i'm speculating it has that
feeling he doesn't actually say it so
let's not focus too much on that the
part that's
hilarious is that in this interview
ron johnson says i wasn't scared because
the protesters
were trump people who loved the country
and wanted the election overturned
they're on his side so to speak but
during the recent congressional
testimony
he used his question and answer time to
suggest
that they were not really trump
supporters on january 6th
but they were fake trump supporters this
was just a couple of weeks ago remember
this clip
thousands of people i passed or who
passed me along constitution avenue some
were indignant
and contemptuous of congress but not one
appeared angry or incited to riot
many of the marchers were families with
small children many were elderly
overweight or just plain tired
or frail traits not typically attributed
to the riot prone
many wore pro-police shirts or carried
pro-police
black and blue flags although the crowd
represented a broad cross-section of
americans mostly working class by their
appearance
and manner of speech some people stood
out a very few didn't share the jovial
friendly earnest demeanor of the great
majority
some obviously didn't fit in and he
describes
four different types of people plain
closed militants
agents provocateurs fake trump
protesters
and then disciplined uniform column of
attackers i think these are the people
that
probably plan this so are you noticing
the absurdity of this
in february during the hearings about
trump supporters who did the riots ron
johnson floats the idea they weren't
really trump supporters
they were fake trump supporters they
were provocateurs but
now he's asked in an interview did you
feel threatened he says
why would i feel threatened these are
just people who love america and they
wanted me to vote a certain way
they wanted me to object to the
electoral account wait a second ron
two weeks ago you said they weren't real
trump supporters
now you say they are and that's why you
didn't feel threatened how
can both possibly be true which one does
he actually believe
i think we know which one i think he
believes they were trump supporters
and he was super comfortable with the
fascist
authoritarian rioters who were seeking
to overturn the election
because they're on his side had they
been anti-fascist
protesters he would have been very very
scared and you tell me whether you think
that that's ideology-based
or race-based or whatever the case may
be a disgusting guy
never fails to impress that upon me and
this is just one example of
i actually believe there's two layers to
this
when elected officials like this guy
talk about they might
have been fake trump supporters i don't
think any of them believe it
when they talk about antifa was spotted
or
uh the no real it's a no true scotsman
fallacy
no real trump supporter would riot
therefore anyone rioting could not have
been a trump supporter
i don't think the elected officials
believe it for a second but
unfortunately
a lot of their constituents do and i've
seen
some people i went to high school with i
went to a very
diverse high school ideologically so to
speak
um people i went to high school with
i've seen genuinely posting on facebook
that
they believe it was antifa in disguise
they don't believe that they were actual
trump supporters that it was antifa in
disguise
that got all the trump flags and the
trump hats and first went to the rally
and also posted on facebook for weeks
that they were going to be there and
their entire facebook persona was staged
to look like
some people really fell for this
obviously false notion so
when ron johnson floated it two weeks
ago three weeks ago
i didn't really believe he believed it
uh now
it becomes very clear and truly
just a bottom feeder disgusting
disgusting guy